[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the top 10
overpowered quirks in boku no hero in
the past we made a video talking about
the top 10 strongest quirks in terms of
fighting and for that video we had to
consider things like how practical the
quirks power is in a fight and how
effectively the power of the quirk can
be controlled but for this video we are
throwing all of that out the window and
we will be looking at the top 10 quirks
in terms of their raw power and
potential regardless of whether they are
suited for fighting or something
completely different the idea for this
video was inspired by my good friend NOx
Taku who makes excellent analysis videos
of overpowered characters including all
might from boku no hero so be sure to
check him out linked in the description
and of course if you enjoyed the MHA
content on this channel and you want to
see more you can let me know by leaving
a like and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and missouri
smash that notification bell shout out
to missouri just the heads up this video
will contain manga spoilers because some
of these quirks have not even appeared
in the anime yet they are only in the
manga so proceed with caution and now
let's get it started at number 10 we
have dark shadow a quirk used by class 1
a student cochlea me as a result of his
quirk cochlea me has a shadow like
entity inside of his body and he can
summon this entity to emerge from his
body and perform various actions
including attacks defending and even
helping cochlea me move faster with the
use of its dark limbs dark shadow can be
effective at both close range and long
range which is a huge advantage in
battle and during the day when there is
lots of light dark shadow is a solid
quirk that is easy for Takayama to
control however when there is an absence
of light such as at night and somewhere
away from artificial lighting the nature
of dark shadow changes completely dark
shadow itself appears to be an entity
separate from Takuya me it appears to
have its own personality and when it is
exposed to total darkness dark shadow
has the potential to become an
incredible
powerful and ruthless monster during the
forest training camp argh we learn a lot
more about the true nature of this quirk
the combination of darkness and takla me
feeling strong emotions such as regret
that he didn't prevent his friend Shoji
from being injured result in dark shadow
going berserk in such cases Tok Liam he
loses control of the quirk and dark
shadow goes on a ruthless rampage when
it is in berserk mode dark shadow is so
insanely powerful that it can take out
dozens of massive trees with a single
blow and in its berserk form dark shadow
is able to easily defeat the villain
moonfish within seconds after both
Bakugan and Todoroki struggled to defend
against him in a two-on-one matchup so
in ideal conditions for dark shadow near
total darkness and takla me feeling
extremely emotional dark shadow is
easily one of the strongest and most
overpowered quirks in boku no hero the
only reason that he doesn't rank even
higher on this list is that it has such
clear limitations during the day or in
places where there is a lot of
artificial lighting dark shadow will not
be nearly as strong and dark shadow is
also going to be weak against the types
of quirks that produce light such as
fire based quirks at number 9 we have
manifest manifest as a quirk used by
third-year you a student and member of
the big three Tamaki amagiri whose hero
name is Sun eater and manifest allows
its user to transform his body in a very
unique way namely Tamaki can manifest on
his body the properties of the things he
eats so for example he can turn his
fingers into tentacles after eating
octopus along with that
Tamaki can manifest the properties of
multiple different substances at the
same time and combined them on his body
so for example if he eats both octopus
and crab he can manifest a claw and
tentacles on his hand at the same time
which creates a more complex combo
weapon and if that wasn't enough if he
consumes objects that are not
necessarily
food such as a small piece of crystal he
can manifest hardened crystals on his
body as well the ability to manifest the
properties of the things he consumes
only lasts for as long as he has the
objects in his system so to use the
medical term basically until he poops
them out for this reason Tamaki does his
best to consume a variety of different
useful foods every day so that he can
always be ready in case he needs to use
his quirk despite still being only a
student Tamaki was able to use his quirk
to defeat multiple seasoned villains at
the same time by himself because of its
versatility and ability to combine
multiple foods and other items into a
powerful and complex weapon we
absolutely had to include manifest on
this list at number eight we have
creation used by class 1 a student
momoyo rosu creation enables its user to
create inorganic objects from their body
as long as the skin is exposed in that
particular spot unlike sun-eater's quirk
creation cannot manifest living
organisms but as long as she is familiar
with the atomic makeup of an object Momo
can created by breaking down the fat in
her body on a molecular level and then
reshaping it into the object in question
the bigger the object she wants to
produce the more of her skin needs to be
exposed and body fat is required to
produce the object so Momo has to eat a
lot in order to always have enough fat
stored up to use her cleric quickly as
someone who loves to eat this isn't a
huge drawback for me and despite its
limitations the truly incredible thing
about creation is that it can create
everything from simple objects like a
sword to complex technological gadgets
like grenades and tracking devices as
long as she understands the atomic
composition of the object Momo can
create it so whether you need bricks of
gold or a rocket launcher Momo has you
covered because of how versatile this
quirk is and how many different things
it can easily produce at will
creation lands at number eight on our
list of the most overpowered quirks at
number seven
used by legal villains member Itsuki
risako aka mr. compress this quirk
enables the user to shrink anything
inside a specific circular area into a
small marble all of the user has to do
is touch something in order to instantly
shrink it and he can then use this on
humans in order to trap them inside the
marble and render them powerless without
actually hurting them in essence this
means that as long as the user of
compressed can get close enough to his
opponent he can trap them and even
kidnap them if he wishes to do that no
matter how strong the opponent's quirk
might be on top of that if he wants to
mr. compress can use the quirk on only a
part of someone's body instead of the
whole body which would effectively rip
the opponent apart and killed them
instantly
mr. compress can even use the quirk on
himself
shrinking himself for a brief moment in
order to avoid an enemy attack the clerk
can also be used on nonliving things so
for example the user could dig a hole on
the ground by shrinking sections of the
earth or even take down a building by
shrinking parts of the structure until
the rest collapses along with being able
to compress things at will mr. compress
can also turn them back to normal
whenever he wishes just by snapping his
fingers so for instance he can shrink
down a big rock into a small marble then
throw the marble at his opponent and
snap his fingers the marble will then
turn into a huge rock as it hits the
opponent and he can do this with
multiple marbles at the same time
potentially causing unprecedented
destruction because of the many
different uses of this quirk from
shrinking people without harming them to
ripping them to shreds and from using
the Kirk on yourself to avoid enemy
attacks to using it to throw huge
objects at your opponent without them
even realizing what's happening before
it's too late
compress ranks at number 7 on our list
at number 6 black hole a quirk used by
space hero 13 black hole enables its
user to generate small black holes that
can suck in and disintegrate both matter
and light on an atomic level which means
that this quirk can destroy virtually
anything black hole is so overpowered
that it is considered highly danger
it can suck up and destroy anything in
its path including objects human beings
and even pure energy such as light space
hero 13 uses the Kirk primarily to get
rid of hazardous debris during rescue
missions but we're not actually sure if
there is a clear limit to this quirks
power if the user ever chose to use it
to its full extent
if the quirk has no limits then it could
potentially suck up entire cities or
worse if not kept under tight control
while this quirk only generates mini
black holes the power of actual black
holes in space is enough to make us
realize that this quirk could
theoretically have the most devastating
destructive potential in the entire
series however this quirk is definitely
not unstoppable because we saw cooter
giddy using his own quirk warp gate to
turn black hole back on its own user
during the usj arc for this reason black
hole is at number 6 well at number 5 we
have warp gate used by Kudo Geary
considered an extremely rare type of
quirk even in the world of boku no hero
because of its overpowered nature warp
gate allows its user to create portals
out of the black fog that surrounds him
and then teleport objects and people to
another location or bring objects and
people from another location to his
current one on top of that if he wishes
the user can also very quickly create a
bunch of mini portals that he can then
use in battle either to stop people from
fighting like he did with shigaraki
versus toga and dobby or to use an
opponent's power against them like he
did in the battle with space hero 13 if
anyone happens to become stuck inside
warp gate when the gate closes they will
be ripped apart as a result so this
quirk can also be very deadly kudo Gaeta
uses the fog surrounding him to hide his
own body making him harder to take down
but his body is always in there
somewhere the only known limitation of
warp gate is that it's user must know
the exact location in which the portals
are going to open for example he can't
simply decide to teleport into all mites
bedroom if he doesn't know where exactly
all might lives we don't know the exact
range of the quirk but if the range is
unlimited and corrugator can use it
Laporte anywhere in the world as long as
he knows the coordinates then this is
definitely an insanely overpowered quirk
however even if he can only use it
within a certain geographical area such
as an entire city or all of Japan this
would still be an Opie Kirk and that is
why it ranks at number five on our list
at number 4 we have overhaul a quirk
used by the villain chisaki
also known as overhaul this quirk allows
its user to disintegrate anything he
touches as long as he touches it with at
least a finger he can kill someone
instantly by simply disintegrating them
but the really crazy thing is that if he
chooses to reassemble someone ride after
disintegrating them
ji-suk he can actually bring them back
to life and he has done this before with
people such as rapa who is one of his
underlings the user of this quirk can
control how much of someone's body is
actually disintegrated and if he chooses
not to kill someone but merely break
down parts of their body he can then
reassemble those parts and all of the
past injuries and illnesses within the
body will have been cured the quirk can
also be used on inorganic matter such as
walls and earth allowing the user to
disassemble and reassemble the
battlefield around him in order to gain
an advantage over the opponent on top of
all of that if he disassembles parts of
his own body at the same time as the
parts of someone else's body
chisaki can reassemble them in a way
that essentially fuses the two people
together creating a fused and even more
powerful version of himself we see this
ability on full display during Chi sakis
epic showdown against Deku like
shigaraki chisaki appears incapable of
simply turning his quark off so he wears
special gloves that allow him to keep
his power in check another drawback is
that using his quirk appears to have
physical consequences on chi sake it
leads him to develop a rash and itchy
butt despite these minor drawbacks
overhauls ability to destroy and put
back together everything around him
including inorganic objects human bodies
and even his own body make this one of
the most overpowered quirks in the world
of boku no hero
and that is why overhaul lands at number
4
on our list at number three we have one
for all a quark used by all might and of
course deku one for all is a unique
transferable quark that was possessed by
seven other people in the past before
being passed on from all-mighty Deku the
ninth and current user one for all is in
fact a synthesis of two previously
separate quirks a quirk that stockpiles
power and a quirk that allows quirks to
be willingly transferred from one person
to another
the stockpiling side of one for all
gives its users superhuman strength
stamina agility speed and reflexes as we
learn from all might after he transfers
one for all to Deku once the quirk is
transferred from one person to another
the one who transfers it can still make
use of some leftover members of the
quark although they will eventually run
out the true workings of one for all
remain a mystery in many ways and we all
have to remember the mysterious way in
which deck who was able to break through
Shin Souls mind-control quark during the
school tournament art it appears that
the previous users of one-for-all were
somehow able to awaken inside of Deku
and bring him back to his senses
one for all also appears to become more
powerful as it is passed on from one
person to another because the Kirk
stalks files powers so the more people
use it the more power is stockpiled so
using this logic even though the
previous seven users of one-for-all were
not able to defeat the villain known as
all-4-one once all might gets the power
he is able to get the better of all four
one on two separate occasions the
immense power of one for all is clearly
evident throughout the series almighty
is able to become the number one pro
hero because of the power of this work
and Deku even as a student who is still
learning to master one for all is able
to defeat much more experienced villains
like muscular and gentle on his own
because of this quark Deku is even able
to defeat Qi Saki aka overhaul but not
quite on his own one for all has some
drawbacks such as the fact that until
the quark is mastered it will cause
serious damage to the user's body but
both Almighty and ik who have proven
that with rigorous training the
drawbacks of this quark can be
mitigated after watching both almighty
and Deku destroying powerful villains
left and right it can be tempting to
think that one for all is the most
overpowered clerk in boku no hero
however there are actually two quirks
that are even more Opie than this one
and number two rewind a quirk used by
Eddy a completely unique quirk unlike
anything that anyone has ever seen
before this quirk allows its user to
rewind another person's body to a
previous state an individual who is
touching Eddy directly when the clerk
activates will have their bodies return
to a previous state and actually the
reason that that kou manages to defeat
overhaul in the first place is because
Eddy was holding on to him and allowing
him to use 100% of one for all's power
because every time that who used it and
damaged his body arey squirt would
remind his body to back before he was
injured Aerys quirk is so potent that
chisaki used her blood to create bullets
that would make their target lose the
ability to use their quirk because their
bodies would essentially be rewound to a
time before their quirks had even
manifested on top of that Aries squirt
can rewind a person's body too before
they even existed literally wiping them
out of existence in a flash because
Eddie is still a child she is unable to
control her quirks so we don't know its
true potential
but Chiaki believes that once she
masters her quirk arey could devolve the
entire human race to their primal state
a quirk like this with the ability to
take away the quirks of others heal
people from all injuries instantly or
even erase them out of existence
in an instant is already a seriously
overpowered quirk but thinking about the
possibility that after mastering her
quirk Eddy could potentially dictate the
evolution of the entire human race is
the reason that rewind makes it to
number 2 on our list before we get to
number 1 here are some honorable
mentions first we have musculars muscle
augmentation quirk this quirk gives its
user the ability to enhance their
physical strength to an incredible
extent by amplifying their muscle
Viper's this definitely looks like a
really really strong work but we only
see it briefly because muscular is
defeated by Deku even though Deku is
just an amateur student at the time
which is why this quark didn't quite
make our list then we have Totoro Keys
have called half hot this is of course
the ability to use both fire and ice
based moves at the same time and it is
definitely an Opie quirk that ranked
very high on our list of the top 10
strongest quirks in battle however it
just missed out on this list because of
the strong competition from the other
quirks and finally we have meteos
permeation this quirk gives its user the
ability to move their entire body or
parts of their body through solid
objects including walls the ground the
ceiling and so on while this quirk can
be incredibly effective when mastered
horikoshi goes out of his way to tell us
that this quirk is extremely hard to use
and torturous to master to the point
that the strength of this quirk depends
more on meteos unflinching determination
then on the open nature of the quirk
itself and that is why it didn't quite
make our list and now at number one the
most overpowered quirk in boku no hero
is all for one used by Shiga Rocky's
master and the master mind behind the
League of villains also known as all for
one this quirk allows its user to steal
the quirks of others after stealing the
quirks the user can use them himself
including combining multiple quirks
inside one person to create extremely
effective offensive and defensive
techniques just think about some of the
strongest and most opie quirks out there
and then think about being able to steal
those quirks and combine them all in one
person the user of all for one can
combine multiple stolen quirks in order
to create more powerful super quirks
that would never have occurred naturally
and of course even one for all is itself
such a quirk which was essentially
created by all-4-one in Chapter 90 we
even learned that all-4-one can forcibly
activate the quirks of others as he
forcibly activates Kudo Geary's quirk
warp
in order to evacuate shigaraki and the
others before they can be arrested and
if that wasn't Opie enough
all-4-one can even transfer stolen
quirks on to other people
meaning that he can essentially create
his own army of villains with super
powered combo quirks and of course the
nomu are just one of all four ones many
projects I think that in terms of
potential all four one is the single
most opaque work in the world of boku no
hero stealing the quirks of others
combining them to create more powerful
super quarks that would never have
occurred naturally and also being able
to create an army of super powered
fighters by giving them stolen quirks
that they never could have gotten
otherwise is like the definition of Opie
and for that reason all-4-one is number
one on our list of the most overpowered
quirks and that is it for this video
everybody if you enjoyed it be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you want
to see more videos like this don't
forget to subscribe and Missouri smash
that notification bell if you want to
give us ideas for future videos be sure
to follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and let us know and of
course feel free to let me know down in
the comments if you agreed with this
list or if you would change some things
around I'd love to hear from you as
always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]